today on the matt well show one of the
largest and oldest confederate statues
has come down in virginia but uh it's
what they plan to put in its place that
really tells the story i think the
campaign to take down confederate
statues and monuments was never really
about the confederacy or about slavery
as much as the mob insisted that it was
i'll explain what was really about today
also the state department continues to
issue stern verbal warnings to the
taliban over their lack of inclusivity
and larry elder is physically attacked
by a crazed leftist in california who
who's wearing a monkey mask something
tells me that this would be headline
news if this was a democrat who was
attacked and alexandra casa cortez has
made her scientific case for why men can
menstruate we will hear her out
maybe she makes a good case we'll find
out today on the matt wall show
well i'm always telling you about my
pillow and you know by now that my
pillow hopefully you know from
experience my pillow has a passion to
help everybody get the best sleep of
their lives my pillow didn't stop by
simply creating the best pillow though a
pillow that i as we are have been on our
travels and have stayed at serial killer
motels and in warehouses um i i
unfortunately have not had my pillows i
haven't been getting the best sleep of
my life but um but i miss it
and that's why when i get home i can't
wait to get back to my my pillow and our
giza dream bed sheets that's the latest
thing they've got from my pillow uh my
pillow found the world's best cotton
called giza it's ultra soft and
breathable but extremely durable my
pillow sheets come with a 60-day
money-back guarantee and a 10-year
warranty the first night you sleep on
giza sheets you will never want to sleep
on anything else giza street sheets come
in a variety of sizes and colors my
pillow's latest incredible deal is the
sale of the year for a limited time
you'll receive 50 off the giza dream
sheets um you'll receive a set for as
low as 49.99 so go to mypillow.com and
click on the radio listener square and
use promo code dailywire there you'll
find not only this amazing offer but
also deep discounts on all my pillow
products including the my pillow
mattress topper my pillow towel sets and
so much more call 1-800-651-1148
use promo code dailywire go to
mypillow.com make sure to use promo code
daily wire
all right as we continue our tour of who
knows where broadcasting live today from
what appears to maybe be my
psychiatrist's office i'm not sure to
start with let me reiterate something
that i mentioned on the show yesterday
after months of waiting and and build up
uh the time has finally come the moment
that that all of the people of the earth
have been waiting for i think the sweet
baby gang t-shirts are finally on sale
now you can officially now like show
your pride in this movement that we have
that we have built together
um and even more important than that i
think
you can uh it gives you an opportunity
to give me your money and that's really
what what any self-respecting cult is
about at the end of the day
now admittedly
um after all of the waiting and
anticipation
the rollout has been somewhat
anti-climactic i mean i don't even have
the shirt myself because we're on the
road
but it wouldn't really be a matt wall
show thing if it wasn't handled in a
weird and anticlimactic way when you
think about it so i think it all works
on the end so go get your shirts today
and you can go to uh the youtube video
that maybe you're watching right now if
you're not go to youtube and click on
the link in the description all right um
from the good news
of the shirts to the not so good news
you may remember back when the mob first
began its campaign to tear down every
statue across the country that it had
deemed problematic
well maybe there wasn't one precisely
definitive start date for that campaign
there have been sort of bursts of
statute toppling fervor here and there
over the course of recent years
but those kind of dwindled and died down
and many of the statues remained
only after george floyd's death was it
decided that all of the bad statues had
to come down all of them everywhere in
the country
and if local authorities would not agree
to take them down then the mob said well
we'll just do it ourselves and we won't
be arrested for it and none of them ever
were
or very few of them were but as this was
happening
i can recall even many conservatives
claiming that um it was not as it
appeared to be
a war on american history or on american
culture at all
this was merely about getting rid of all
those pesky confederate monuments that's
all it was about
we were told
many of those monuments had stood for
over a century
most people weren't bothered by them
for decades and decades but now right
now
it has to happen now they all had to
come down
and and um and that was fine we we were
assured
those of us who said that this will not
stop with the confederate monuments that
this is indeed a war on our history that
it will continue
because the mob has become emboldened
those of us who said that we were
shouted down as conspiracy theorists and
paranoids and racists
and again even conservatives were in the
crowd shouting at us
but of course we were proven right
the mob soon began making the very
predictable argument that hey almost all
of our white historical heroes were
racist by our standards today some of
them were slave owners
uh or at least tacit endorsers of
slavery
and so they have to come down as well
you know why should we let the jefferson
monuments and jefferson's name
remain on on school buildings
he was a slave owner he was racist
and next thing you know statues of the
founding fathers come down uh uh schools
are renamed columbus is cancelled and on
and on and on and there is no end in
sight just recently here's one of the
most recent things a school board in
ontario
literally burned books this is not a
metaphorical book burning which we've
seen a lot of that this is an actual
book burning
and they they called it a flame
purification ceremony
that's what they called it to get rid of
books that were deemed offensive by uh
aboriginal people
now i say all this as a preamble to the
story that i'm going to talk about here
um i say it's it to remind you that
those on my side of this issue
were right you know we were exactly
right
we told you what would happen
we told you where the confederate
monument thing would lead
and we were right so keep that in mind
as we read from this this is from the
daily wire says the largest confederate
monument display in the united states
was removed from public view on
wednesday over a year after governor
ralph northam
called for its removal following the
death of george floyd
and we know that governor northam who
famously wore blackface he's very
offensive he's he's very concerned with
anything that might be considered
racially offensive
um the statue a commemoration to
confederate general robert e lee was
unveiled in the 1890s in a field outside
richmond the 21-foot statue features lee
and a horse back inside atop a 40-foot
granite base the whole monument was six
stories tall
governor ralph northam called for its
removal last year saying that we could
no longer honor a system that was based
on the buying and selling of enslaved
people
he added yes the statue has been there
for a long time but it was wrong then
and it was wrong now well wearing
blackface was wrong then it's wrong now
too
yet here you are northam
um
and the move
to try to take the statue down that
prompted a legal challenge and that went
through the courts and finally they
decided to take it down now
i need to repeat a couple of points that
i've made before about these kinds of
stories
the first
is that for many
decades most people were able to
acknowledge
that somebody like robert e lee
was a significant historical figure
and um and worthy of remembering
and and they were able to view him
within the context of his time
yes he fought for the south he fought
for virginia specifically that's what he
was fighting for his home was in
virginia his family was in virginia he
couldn't bring himself to take up his
sword against his own family against his
sons he didn't favor secession but he
felt called to fight in any case because
that's the sense of duty that that men
of that time had on both sides
um we may not we may we may not
understand a lot of this
now but that was the context of the time
he wasn't racially enlightened by our
standards today that's for sure but then
again literally nobody on earth was
that doesn't excuse slavery
it doesn't excuse any evil perpetrated
by anyone against anybody else
but it does provide context
these are all things that most people
understood at one time
and that was a mark of healing okay that
was a mark of progress
from the time of the civil war
the fact that we can't recognize that
context anymore that we can't stand to
even see the image of any man who fought
on one side of that conflict anymore is
to me a sign of regression it's not a
sign of progress
also as i've also said many times no
matter how you feel about the
confederate monuments
even if when when viewing the issue in a
vacuum
you would prefer if they were taken down
or were never erected in the first place
even if you don't like the monuments
even if you hate the monuments
you still should have opposed them being
taken down like this by this mob for
these reasons right now
it's not good for any decision to be
made at the behest of a hysterical
ideological mob otherwise good decisions
are not good if they're done at
metaphorical or real gun point
there could be good arguments for
removing some of them
but the argument that the mob was making
it doesn't matter what the good
arguments could be
the argument the mob was making and has
made for taking down all of these
statues and not just the confederate
ones is that we have to do it for george
floyd number one and also that america
is a racist country and we have to purge
ourselves of that history and atone for
it
that's why these statues are coming down
there might be better possible reasons
for some of them
but this is the actual reason this is
why they're actually doing it
and if you support what they're doing
then you are at least tacitly supporting
the reason for doing it
now to further demonstrate the point uh
the robert e lee statue that they just
took down which by the way is it's also
worse no worth noting was was a
priceless
and quite impressive work of art
but they cut it into pieces and are just
going to put it in a warehouse somewhere
that's the other thing we hear is that
we're just moving it to a museum
actually in a lot of these cases they're
not moving them to museums they're
destroying them and that's what happened
here
but that statue had a time capsule from
1890 hidden in the base of it
and that time capsule is and i don't
think we know what was in it yeah they
haven't told us
uh but that time capsule is being
removed
and they're replacing it with a new one
here's npr says according to the
governor's office a group of historians
educators
uh artists and state officials worked
together to select nearly 40 submissions
to be placed inside the new time capsule
some of the items include a photo of a
black ballerina taken by a local
richmond photographer in front of the
statue
a kente cloth worn at the 400th
commemoration of 1619
a black lives matter sticker a stop
asian hate flyer an lgbtq pride plan pin
and an expired vial of pfizer's covet 19
vaccine
this is
what the statute toddlers want
not just to get rid of the old history
but to replace it with a new history to
rewrite the story
and these are the objects they choose to
encapsulate our time
they choose objects which tell a story
of mostly imaginary oppression
and of fear
i think that's the main thing that that
people of the future when they open that
time capsule they're going to look at
that and say wow these people were
freaking wimps they were afraid of
everything
um
they've decided
nobody who came before us contributed
anything worth honoring
and this is what they contribute
see this was never about the civil war
it was never about confederacy or
slavery this was always about reshaping
america in their own image
and they've largely succeeded so
that time capsule as much as i hate to
say it really does encapsulate our
period
and at least now archaeologists of the
future when they open it will have
little trouble pinpointing
exactly when everything
started to fall to pieces
now let's get to our five headlines
the one thing i love talking to people
about is magnesium and that that's what
the people in the world are are
in my experience anyway magnesium
breakthrough by by optimizer
specifically this is what will help you
get a nice long night's sleep if you're
having trouble falling asleep or staying
asleep one of the best things you could
possibly do is start getting enough
magnesium
as i always say but please don't run to
the store and buy the first magnesium
supplement that you find most magnesium
supplements use only the two cheapest
synthetic forms not all magnesium
supplements are created equal and since
they're not full spectrum those other
ones they won't fix your magnesium
deficiency or help you sleep better so
you're wasting your time and your money
there are actually seven unique forms of
magnesium and you have to get all of
them if you want to experience its
calming sleep enhancing effects that's
why i recommend magnesium breakthrough
by bio optimizer uh simply take two
capsules before you go to bed and you'll
be amazed by how much better you sleep
for an exclusive offer for my listeners
go to www.magbreakthrough.comwalsh10
to save 10 when you try magnesium
breakthrough and one more thing for a
limited time buy optimizer is also
giving away free bottles of their
best-selling product
p3om and mass zymes with select
purchases so go to magbreakthrough.com
walsh now to get your exclusive 10
discount plus the chance to get more
than 50 worth of supplements for free
and this thing with the female sports
analysts is still going on like they're
still usually it's a day you know when i
when i've gone through this
with the angry internet mob it normally
it's 24 hours
and they move on like less than usually
it's like 12 to 24 hours that's kind of
the the expiration date on most of the
online outrage
um this one is every once in a while you
get to like a 48 hour 36 to 48 hour i
think we're going to this might this
might go 48 hours this might be a 48
hour outrage
because they're still coming after me
and it's
every single
female sports analyst in the country has
to get their dunkin like they all have
to it's like one at a time
uh they all have to
say their piece about it and what i'll
say is
um not gonna get into the whole thing
again
but
after having
listened
to all these people
and having thousands of emotional women
scream at me for the past two days
i actually have reevaluated my original
position and i've come to the conclusion
that um
i'm even more right than i originally
thought
that's what i've realized from all of
this so i thank you i thank the outrage
mom for that all right
let's start with this secretary of state
uh blinken in germany yesterday scolded
the taliban for their lack of
inclusivity every time they do this the
bureaucrats in charge of our government
they get uh ruthlessly mocked and
deservedly so but that doesn't stop them
they don't realize that they're being
laughed at because they're in their
bubbles so here he is at a press
conference in germany talking about the
uh
very disappointed that the taliban is
not inclusive enough
yesterday the taliban named a new
interim government
we're assessing the announcement but
despite professing that a new government
would be inclusive
the announced list of names consists
exclusively of individuals who are
members of the taliban or their close
associates
and no women
we're also concerned by the affiliations
and track records of some of those
individuals
with regard to the composition of this
uh government or or interim government
um
i noted uh the fact that
it certainly does not meet the test of
inclusivity
and it includes
people who
have
very challenging track records
our engagement with the taliban and with
a government interim or or long term
will be for purposes of advancing
the national interest
advancing
our interests the interests of uh of our
of our partners
uh
we have and we will find ways to engage
uh the taliban to engage uh
an interim government
a future government uh to do just that
and to do it in ways that are fully
consistent with uh with our laws
i forgot about the challenging track
record bit that's my favorite part
actually
i thought the inclusivity part was my
favorite but no it's it's the taliban
has a challenging track record well that
is
that's one way to put it
there that might be a useful euphemism
that people maybe you know your daughter
could use that
she comes home brings home a you know
ex-con
murderer that she's dating
well what's what's what's so what's his
background oh he has a
he has a he's a challenging track record
but you know secretary of state blanket
he is
he's not angry
he's disappointed he's disappointed in
the taliban for not being more inclusive
and i'm sure the taliban is sitting you
know they're sitting in there in their
caves well they used to be in caves now
they're in their palaces
that they took over and they're sitting
there and uh they're they're talking to
each other they're saying you
know i i thought we had the right idea
with all of this uh
jihad stuff and depressing women
stoning people to death stoning women to
death for showing their faces i thought
we had a but if if if secretary of state
blanken is disappointed in us then i
think we need to
i think it might be time to reevaluate
some things i'm sure the taliban is
saying that all right next uh larry
elder
of course running for governor of
california
was walking through los angeles
yesterday and here's something that if
you follow conservative media you've
probably already seen this
if you don't follow it
then you haven't seen this but you
certainly would well you're about to
we'll play the clip what you're about to
see here
just imagine
any
non-white democrat
experiencing exactly what we're going to
see with larry elder
and it would be non-stop news across the
country headlines for two weeks easily
here it is
might have been hard to tell what was
going on there if you weren't watching
the video uh that was
a leftist woman
in a gorilla mask
running up and throwing an egg at larry
elder and she missed
you know frankly she was thrown like a
girl and she did miss
but then his security goes up and she's
getting the securities
guys face say do something
say prob saying that he that that she
would uh i think her words were f him up
this little tiny scrawny that's that's
always frustrating when you see these
videos
that these
antifa wusses all get away with that
um because the security guy know i
assume that was security he he knows
that if he responds at all even though
at that point i mean he's being
physically assaulted now by this woman
if he responds at all physically then
he's going to be the one who ends up in
jail this is california after all
now as i said there's there's
no question at all that if this happened
to a black democrat or any non-white
democrat
uh this would be
headline news two weeks i mean it would
be like the only thing you heard about
um and there's no doubt about that
now a lot of people on the right are
pointing that out and putting it out for
good reason
and you're also hearing that uh this is
this is racist this is racism towards
larry elder
uh
i mean i'm i'm fine with that accusation
or or that
interpretation of the events because if
it was reversed that's what everybody
would be saying so that's fair enough
but i will say in reality i don't think
it actually is
racism exactly
uh i think there was a racist message
she was trying to send i mean why else
would she be
dressed like that
but um
does she hate larry elder because
he's black
probably not
i mean if he was the exact same guy
exact same skin color
and he was singing the tune that she
that she prefers
uh you know and he was and he had the
blm t-shirt and he was saying tran black
trans lives matter or something and he's
wearing a t-shirt that said that then
then she wouldn't have done that
i think
what it is more so than racism this is
just that people on that side
especially the radicals antifa and
everything
they just don't recognize the humanity
of anybody who disagrees with them
so if you disagree with them if you have
a
worldview that differs from their own
then all bets are off
they could be racist towards you they
could be sexist towards you they could
do anything and kill you i mean they can
do whatever they want
because you're not a person anymore
no matter what your race is
uh and that applies regardless of race
so that's what this is actually that
doesn't make it better
it's just as bad
but that's what's actually happening
here it's not it's not so much
oh we hate larry elder because he's a
black man it's
he disagrees with us so he's a piece of
garbage and worthless and so we can
treat him however we want and this is
how we're going to treat him
if his if his race contributes at all to
the treatment um
and it might
it's because people on the left feel
that
if you're black then they then they own
you
you you you owe something to them
and if you disagree with them especially
if you're running for governor of
california as a republican how dare you
then um not only do they hate you for
your worldview but also on top of it
they consider you a traitor to them
all right we had the clip yesterday of
aoc referring to menstruating people
right after calling them women she was
on cnn she was kind of fluctuating
between the two she couldn't really
figure out
how to navigate this well later that
afternoon she was reacting to the media
reports
about her you know saying menstruating
people and this is what she she tweeted
she said
in response to a daily mail headline the
headline was aoc calls women
menstruating people while explaining the
female body
aoc says not just women trans men and
non-binary people can also menstruate
some women also don't mend straight for
many reasons including surviving cancer
that require a hysterectomy gop mad at
this or protect are protecting the
patriarchal idea that women are most
valuable as uterus holders
and then she continues trans to spirit
and non-binary people have always
existed and will always exist people can
stay mad about that if they want or they
can grow up
uh
okay first of all
this thing they do where they where they
you know bring up women who can't
menstruate women who can't have babies
yeah yeah we know about that that has
that has nothing to do with anything
nobody ever claimed
that only that all women
can conceive children and give birth
nobody ever said that
the claim aoc is that only women
can conceive children within themselves
and give birth
only women can bear children not that
every woman can
certainly not that every woman does but
that only women can
which means if someone is bearing
children if someone is pregnant then you
know 100 of the time that's a woman
that's the claim that we're making
as far as this idea that trans
two-spirit and non-binary people have
always existed will always exist that's
a historical nonsense uh it's it's
simply not true at all
um two-spirit is what the left will
claim that two-spirit is the the native
american conception of of transgenderism
which it isn't
i mean this was something that was
mostly invented this two-spirit thing
was mostly invented by um the lgbt lobby
trans people
existing in other cultures throughout
history is just not true
okay
you you may be able to find them you can
find examples throughout history you can
find examples in the world today and
other cultures
of um
of cultures that have gender roles that
are different from our own you know
cultures that have slightly different
ideas about what men are supposed to do
and what women are supposed to do you
can also find examples especially in the
world today across the world of men in
in some cultures um
dressing and acting like the women in
those cultures
you could find cross-dressers across the
world you could find them throughout
history
that's certainly the case nobody ever
denied that
what you won't find
in history
or anywhere outside of modern western
culture
is the idea that a man can literally
actually be a woman
you might you might find men acting as
women
dressing as women you might find that
but you're not going to find this idea
that a man actually is one in reality
that is a uniquely modern and western
conception
it doesn't exist anywhere else
and it didn't even exist here until very
recently
this is actually that you know trans
women are women
this is the most recent evolution or
devolution
of the um of transgender ideology
because you may remember for
you know
for many years we heard about this i can
remember even when i was growing up
uh we heard about gender and sex and how
these are two different things and
someone can have a uh a you know a male
sex but they identify more with the with
the female gender the woman gender
so these are two separate and distinct
things
it's only been in the last few years
that that distinction has been collapsed
again
and now we're being told by the same
people who told us that there was this
distinction now they're saying no no
they're the same thing really i mean sex
is is fluid and subjective so is gender
it's all the same thing and if you sit
down and you ask them you say okay
what's the difference now what do we
need what do you even mean anymore when
you're talking about gender and sex why
do we why do we need both terms
they'll have no answer they have no
coherent answer for that
so
it's it's not even enough to say that
this is unique to our culture it's like
it's unique to the last few years in our
culture that's how recent and new and uh
also insane it is all right howard stern
had some thoughts about people who don't
get vaccinated fact he was on his show
he started by
laughing and mocking
the uh a few conservative radio hosts
who were
said they didn't want to get vaccinated
and then they died of coronavirus and
that's happened a few times
and howard stern thinks that's hilarious
he had a lot of fun with that i mean
these are people you know just normal
people who died they had families and
kids howard stern thought it was
hilarious and then he starts talking
about in general people who don't want
to get vaccinated and this this was his
uh his thoughts about it
i tell you what as far as i remember
when i went to school
you had to get a measles vaccine you had
to get a mumps vaccine you had to get
there was a ton of them you got polio
in order to go to school you have to
have certain vaccines when are we going
to stop putting up with the idiots in
this country and just say you now it's
mandatory to get vaccinated
their freedom i want my freedom to live
i want to get out of the house already i
want to go next door and play chess
you remember when howard stern was
you know counter culture
rebellious edgy
and this is what he is now this is the
problem
stick around too long on the scene he's
in what is he in his 70s now
should have retired years ago
he's this cranky old man complaining
because he wants to leave his house and
play chess and take pictures
go ahead and do that no one's stopping
you howard go ahead leave leave your
house who said you can't you're
vaccinated
whoever you want to play chess with i'm
assuming
i mean you i'm assuming you don't
comport with the unclean unvaccinated
type so they're vaccinated
put on your mat put on five masks
go to your friend's house and play chess
if you want to have him wear five masks
too
no one's stopping you from doing that
this this rich old guy
hiding in his home
trembling in fear because people who are
far away from him are not vaccinated
pose no threat to him whatsoever
but this this uh statement of f your
freedoms
howard stern's not the first one to say
that
we've been hearing that more and more
that is a that is a very startling
development
in a country
when you have people especially in
america it was built on this idea of
freedom
and we always thought
you know i've talked in the past about
what what is it as as americans we say
we're the united states of america what
is it that unites us anymore how are we
one people or one country what what
unifying thing is there aside from
geography and even the geography isn't
very unifying anymore because we've
erased the borders so those are
indistinct as well so what is it aside
from the fact that we all basically live
in the same kind of region
of the globe uh what what holds us all
together
what do we have in common as americans
and i've been saying for years there's
really nothing
but the one answer that i've always
gotten from from people
is that uh well we all we all believe in
freedom that's what we have in common
now even if that was true i'm not sure
that it's enough to make a real country
a real people you know
but it's not true it hasn't been true
for a while and now they're being open
about it
they're saying f your freedom
f your freedom i want to feel safer
i will gladly trade your freedom for my
safety
and not even for my safety but for my
feeling of safety
because howard stern's safety is not at
all being jeopardized by any
unvaccinated person
living in his bubble in his rich
neighborhood where everybody is
vaccinated
so what he's saying and he's not the
only one
is
i will i'll take your freedom away just
so i can feel better
it's bad enough when we've got many
americans who feel that way and it's
been like that for for years
but now that they're saying it f your
freedom
that's a bad sign nothing good that we
don't go anywhere
you know there's nothing good comes from
that
there is no happy ending that begins
with f your freedoms
all right um another clip that i've had
that i've wanted to play for a couple
days there's been a lot of this kind of
thing in response to the flooding that
happened in new york city but um here's
one example eric adams mayoral candidate
blaming the floods on the human race and
especially on america
uh uniquely for screwing up the planet
here he is
i'm curious what needs to change in your
mind to prepare new york city for the
next storm
and can can you guarantee that it'll get
done on time
uh no you can't and what's going to
prepare us is honesty let's be clear we
screwed up our planet and this is the
byproduct of that screw-up and we have
to be honest about how do we move our
country and our cities in the right
direction and it's not going to be done
by the next storm uh we're not going to
build out our entire sewer systems uh
we're not going to do what copenhagen
did overnight uh we need to be honest if
300 years or 100 years ago we were
receiving storms of this magnitude we
would have built differently now we're
here and now it's time to visit all of
these countries across the globe that
made the adjust adjustments we must do
the same something uh that we can do
within a short period of time like
building retaining pools inside our
parks now and then we have long-term
plans as we build out our sewer system
we can't build it out based on the
previous rainfalls we have to build it
up based on monsoons and if we're not
honest about this conversation we're
going to lose more lives and we're going
to see a greater level of property
damage in our city
to be clear he's talking about what
policies can be put in place to stop the
rain
okay this is like a he might as well
start doing a rain dance this this is
what he's talking about what policies
can we put in place even just in new
york city
to stop it from raining
at least as much as as it did as it has
uh meanwhile the mainstream media is
trumpeting a report that says one in
three americans have lived through a
weather disaster this summer this this
report got a lot of attention a few days
ago one in three americans have lived
through a weather a weather disaster
quote unquote this summer
and that's the highest number in forever
and it's a more more proof that we're
heading towards the end times they tell
us now you hear that you think well okay
how do you define weather disaster
and also
doesn't that speak more to
the places that americans
want to live and tend to congregate
doesn't that factor into this
i i will say as i've said before about
climate change
um
first of all
you know
most of the people who are panicking
over climate change have no sense
we talk about historical context
well when we're discussing
global patterns
the historical context has to go
much farther back than the 19th century
you got to go back
millions of years
and so when eric adams says well we've
never had storms like this in in new
york
uh i'm not convinced that that's true
even just looking at the last few
decades
but if we look at that region of the
planet and extend
the scope of our search
over hundreds and thousands of years how
can you even make that statement
the climate has changed dramatically it
goes in dramatic cycles over the course
of thousands and millions of years it's
hard for us to
see it that way it's hard for us to
really place ourselves within within a
timeline that stretches for millions and
billions of years
but when you're talking about the
climate you have to do that you have to
take that into account you have to take
into account the natural cycles of the
globe
and this is one of the reasons why
i'm sorry i don't i don't care about
climate change i just don't care about
it
and the only difference between me and
most americans
even a lot of the americans who pretend
to care about it is just i'm saying it
out loud
it's pretty clear that almost nobody
despite all the hectoring from aoc and
eric adams and everybody else al gore
it's pretty clear that no one actually
cares about it
even the people who are doing the
hectoring famously they get on
private jets they live in big houses
they keep their lights on
they're making like no sacrifices at all
they claim to believe that if we don't
make serious sacrifices right now the
whole world could actually end within a
decade or or a few
or or at best
the earth
lingers on but we have destroyed
civilization for our children our
grandchildren that's what they're saying
and they make no changes to their lives
now that doesn't mean just because you
notice that someone
isn't living according to
the beliefs that they profess that
doesn't mean that the beliefs are wrong
but when you see that it's that it's
this widespread and ubiquitous
that almost all of the people pretending
to care about this clearly in their own
lives don't that's when you start to
suspect you start to suspect that
there's something going on here
so i'll say it out loud
i don't care uh intuitively
it doesn't make sense to me
that
the american government in the year 2021
could pass some kind of policy
that is going to significantly change
the cycles of the earth and of the
climate and weather
but even if it's true
which i really don't buy
but even if it is
according to everything we're hearing
from these people we're doomed anyway
like we would all have to stop using
electricity and
and
basically embrace a return to the stone
age right now
and not just here but across the globe
in order to make any kind of dent and
that's not going to happen so
either
you know there's really nothing we can
do to change the weather
or
um
there's something we can do but we're
not doing it and no one is going to do
it
and what that leads me to is let's
continue to live our lives
there are a lot of things to worry about
a lot of things to be afraid of we don't
need to put this on the list
you know the thing about living in
biden's america is that uh when he on
the rare occasion he actually gives a
press conference it'll be very difficult
to understand
what he's saying and that's if you're if
that's if your hearing is perfect um it
can be difficult to understand but
imagine if you have hearing loss uh how
much more difficult it must be to even
understand what our president is trying
to tell us and that's why you've got to
check out md hearing aid md hearing aid
is an fda registered rechargeable
hearing aid that costs a fraction of
what typical hearing aids cost the
average price of a hearing aid in
america is over two thousand four
hundred dollars a pair but their vault
plus model is just three hundred dollars
each when you buy a pair md hearing aid
was found by an ent surgeon who uh saw
how many of his patients needed hearing
aids but couldn't afford them he made
his mission develop a quality hearing
aid that can that anybody can afford
their sleek design fits so well no one
will even know that you're wearing it
plus it's rechargeable with battery life
that lasts up to 30 hours
if you forget to take your hearing aids
off in the shower
which is a big problem for people that
have hearing aids nothing to worry about
there the vault plus is water resistant
in up to three feet of water you don't
even need a prescription or a doctor's
appointment you buy it directly from
them with audiologists and licensed
hearing specialists available seven days
a week md hearing aid
has brought affordable hearing to over
600 000 satisfied customers if you want
to be one of those here's what you have
to do it's time to reclaim claim your
life from hearing loss go to
mdhearingaid.com and use promo code
walsh to buy there to get their buy one
get one 300 each offer plus they're
adding a free extra charging case a 100
value just for listeners of the matt
wall show so head to mdhearingaid.com
and use our promo code walsh or you can
even call them at
1-833-637-1024 that's 1-833-637
all right let's go now to read the
youtube comments uh beau says based on
the room matt's in i can only assume
matt ben is punishing him for having to
judge the sbg anthem well i was in a
warehouse yesterday that is true i was
tied in a chair in a warehouse
uh stank williams says is this the matt
wall show is this the manual show the
latest iteration of the saw movie series
run matt run while you can
uh
pedagory says the secret to man's odd
locations he's been doing his videos
from is that he's actually looking for a
good place to set up his sbg cult now
that's a good theory
um
and ben says i'm glad to see they're
finally inching matt back into the car
where he belongs
and yo mama's boo says matt looks like
he's broadcasting from the taliban's
basement do caves have basements that
was a question but yes we have been
broadcasting from a variety of random
and sometimes bizarre places and yes
it's true that we've provided no
explanation for any of this
all i can say is that one day
it will all make sense
in due time
have faith my sweet babies have faith
um
all right staff sergeant sullivan says
43 minute show returning to matt walsh
dark days of 2019 it was it was one of
the shortest shows that i've that i've
done in a long time
i i promised that today i'm going to
continue babbling for at least several
minutes more
uh sloopy says matt you are the code of
silence breaker and i'm more and more
thankful for it every day thank you also
as a woman football fan i agree
wholeheartedly with you i have never
liked women sideline reporters
interviewers analysts for football it
irks me also thanks thank you to the
daily wire for finally providing sbg
merch we're not content with only
t-shirts we want mugs yeah i would like
to have a whole i mean we're starting a
cult after all so we're gonna need a lot
of supplies not just t-shirts
um yeah sloopy you're far from the only
woman who has told me that you agree
with the female analysts and reporters i
mean that's that's the irony of this
whole thing that
yeah there's been a lot of female
reporters have been screaming at me
about this
but but many of the messages that i've
gotten saying hey you know i actually
agree with you have been from women so
go figure and sloopy also
i got to give you credit because i know
that you are
you you you had the very first although
your
uh
spg anthem wasn't in the competition you
had the very first one that we played on
the show and so that is a distinction
that
i think
will hopefully give your life meaning
for the rest of your days
well as we mentioned at the start of the
show we finally have our sweet baby gang
shirt so you can be a member of the gang
or the cult however you wanna look at it
they're selling out so fast uh that you
you don't wanna wait if you've waited
this long don't wait anymore uh you
wanna click the link in the description
to get your order today i'm also being
instructed in this copy to start singing
the spg anthem which will never happen
and my sweet babies know that i would
never sing plus we haven't we haven't
named the the anthem yet officially so i
can't do that
um
but the shirt is a masterpiece and it is
uh
something that will
i i think
brighten your day when you wake up in
the morning and put it on so go and get
that shirt today also if you like the
daily wire backstage then i've got some
extra exciting news for you this october
not only will we be live and on stage at
the famous ryman auditorium right here
in nashville but we're also giving one
lucky member a chance to win two vip
tickets to get front row seats and not
just that but the winner will receive a
1500 gift card to cover travel expenses
and also a meet and greet with backstage
hosts and more so tickets for the ryman
show sold out already so this is your
one chance to get in on the action and
have the best seat in the house actually
so enter when you go to dailywire.com
subscribe and join one of our membership
plans with code backstage for 25 off
your membership if you're already a
member you'll be automatically entered
so get ready because you might just be
on your way to nashville to meet
and watch myself ben shapiro jeremy
barry michael knowles andrew clavin
candace owns next month now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we have someone who at this point
is kind of a dark horse candidate to
become the most canceled person on the
matt wall show that would be demi lovato
the thing about demi lovato is that i
know she's a singer but i couldn't name
one song she's made if i heard a demi
lovato song if i actually heard one i
couldn't tell you that it was her
singing
she's no poo scheisty i guess you could
say uh i'm not an expert in her catalog
the way that i am for my guy pooh
when lovato appears in a cancellation
therefore it's always because of
comments she's made outside of her music
as far as that goes she's been on kind
of a desperate journey in recent years
to discover herself and find an identity
that is true
and real
and that will bring her the most media
attention and that's what's driven her
to come out as a lesbian and then
bisexual and then pansexual and then
non-binary
i think that's the trajectory so when i
saw her name back in the headlines
you know i thought this process was
continuing and now she was coming out as
i don't know a gay disabled polyamorous
aboriginal trans man or a trans man or
something i don't know but that's not
quite what she was up to here's a daily
wire it's a singer and lgbt activist
demi lovato encouraged followers to be a
[ __ ] and make their own porn in a post
to social media promoting prostitution
which was euphemistically described as
sex work
the former disney star posted an image
to her instagram stories monday which
told followers to be a [ __ ] show your
body get naked have all the safe
different consensual sex you want be
kinky masturbate make slash watch porn
make money
just a reminder that being sexual is
okay
okay now
the first problem here is that
this all seems to be based on lovato's
assumption that her audience needs to be
encouraged to act like [ __ ] um the
whole so-called sex positivity movement
revolves around the notion that people
are repressed and ashamed of their
sexuality in our culture and they need
they need a little nudge a little
inspiration
right so they can go out and be their
true [ __ ] selves
but in a country where porn is a billion
dollar industry
and suburban soccer moms have their own
only fan pages
and we fly flags on our embassies to
celebrate sexuality
and people bring their children to
libraries to be read stories to by you
know for drag queen story hour
um
given all of that
i don't think that there's much evidence
of the sort of sexual shyness that
people like demi lovato are trying to
cure then again i mean we're also told
that we need a body positivity movement
in order to encourage fat people
even though most of the country is obese
already
we're told that diet culture is a
problem even as we gorge on fast food
double cheeseburgers
i mean we live in a country
where kfc taco bell hybrid
drive-throughs exist
and people actually go and eat there
and mountain dew exists and people
actually drink it and yeah we hear about
diet culture being the problem so
there's there's kind of a disconnect is
what i'm saying
but the more important point is this
lovato like so many pop stars
is a miserable and lonely person
she's also a heroin addict
now i don't say that as a cheap shot or
to insult her
that's not the point
i just say it because it's true
she's an addict in an identity crisis
who can't even figure out who she is
there is pretty clearly a deep
misery at the core of this person
and this is the case again for so many
of these celebrities and yet these
people still promote lifestyles that
they know from experience
lead only to misery and despair and
self-destruction
that's the first thing you can do when
you hear someone promoting a certain
lifestyle or promoting you know a
certain philosophy of life or promoting
any behavior at all
and and claiming that it will lead you
to happiness and fulfillment first thing
you should do is look at them who is
telling you this
do they appear to be happy and
well-adjusted and fulfilled people
every person
who stands on a stage or sings a song or
posts a message to their millions of
followers on instagram encouraging
people encouraging even the millions of
kids in their audience as well
to objectify themselves to prostitute
themselves
every person who does this
knows that it's not a path to happiness
or fulfillment
they all know it from experience
and this is what makes the lie so great
and so sinister
that it's being told by people who fell
for it themselves and experienced the
consequences and now want other people
to experience those same consequences
too
it's like if somebody you know was
standing on a cliff and they saw water
below and they and they thought that the
water was deep enough so they jumped
into the water
and then they discovered that it's
actually too shallow and they broke
their legs and rather than warning
people who are still standing on the
cliff and saying no don't do it i just
broke my legs don't make the mistake i
did
instead they shot up yeah come on down
the water's great
i guess this might be a long way of
saying that misery loves company but i
think there's more to it actually
misery convinces itself
that company is the cure
that if other people make the same
miserable decisions that somehow by
majority vote all of the misery will
magically turn into joy
these empty people
think that if they can convince you to
join them in their emptiness then
perhaps you know you'll all be full
again
but it doesn't work
it can never work
the pursuit is fruitless
not to mention unbelievably selfish
and that is why today demi lovato is
again i'm afraid to say
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2021.
today on the ben shapiro show virginia
creates a time capsule so future
generations can learn why america
collapsed and as americans remain
trapped in afghanistan coveted lockdowns
loom and culture war breaks out
everywhere the biden administration has
a new old plan throw money at all the
things that's today on the bench bureau
shall give it a listen